The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
I want to complete
the discussion
on volatility modeling in
the first part of the lecture
today.
And last time we
addressed the definition
of ARCH models, which allow
for time-varying volatility
in modeling the returns of
a financial time series.
And we were looking
last time at modeling
the euro-dollar
exchange rate returns.
And we went through fitting
ARCH models to those returns,
and also looked at fitting the
GARCH model to those returns.
And to recap, the GARCH model
extends upon the ARCH model
by adding some extra terms.
So if you look at this
expression for the GARCH model,
the first two terms for the
time-varying volatility sigma
squared t is a linear
combination of the past sort
of residual returns squared.
That's the ARCH
model, p of those.
So the current
volatility depends
upon what's happened in
excess returns over the last p
periods.
But then we add an
extra term, which
is corresponds to q levels
of the previous volatility.
And so what we're
doing with GARCH
models is adding extra
parameters to the ARCH,
but an advantage of considering
these extra parameters which
relate basically the current
volatility sigma squared t
with the previous or lagged
value sigma squared t
minus j for lags
j is that we may
be able to have a model
with many fewer parameters.
So indeed, if we fit these
models to the exchange rate
returns, what we found last
time-- let me go through
and show that--
was-- basically here
are various fits of the
three cases of ARCH models.
ARCH orders 1, 2, and
10, thinking we maybe
need many lags to
fit volatility.
And then the GARCH model 1,1,
where we only have one ARCH
term and one GARCH term.
And so basically the green line,
or rather the blue line in this
graph, shows the plot of
the fitted GARCH(1,1) model
as compared with
the ARCH models.
Now, in looking
at this graph, one
can actually see
some features of how
these models are fitting
volatility, which
is important to understand.
One is that the ARCH
models have a hard lower
bound on the volatility.
Basically there's
a constant term
in the volatility equation.
And because the additional terms
are squared excess returns,
it-- basically, the volatility
does have the lower bound
of that intercept.
So depending on what range
you fit the data over,
that lower bound is
going to be defined by--
or it will be determined by
the data you're fitting to.
As you increase the ARCH
order, you basically
allow for a greater range of--
or a lower lower bound of that.
And with the GARCH
model you can see
that this blue line
is actually predicting
very different
levels of volatility
over the entire
range of the series.
So it really is
much more flexible.
Now-- and in these fits, we are
assuming Gaussian distributions
for the innovations
in the return series.
We'll soon pursue looking
at alternatives to that,
but let me talk just
a little bit more
about the GARCH model going
back to lecture notes here.
So let me expand this.
OK.
So there's the specification.
The GARCH(1,1) model.
One thing to note is that this
GARCH(1,1) model does relate
to an ARMA, an autoregressive
moving average process
in the squared residuals.
So if we look at the top
line, which is the equation
for the GARCH(1,1) model,
consider eliminating sigma
squared t by using a new
innovation term, little u_t,
which is the difference
between the squared residual
and the true volatility
given by the model.
So if you plug in the difference
between our squared excess
return and the
current volatility,
that should have mean
0 because sigma squared
t, the t-th volatility squared,
is equal to the square--
or is equal to the expectation
of the squared excess residual
return, epsilon_t squared.
So if we plug that
in, we basically
get an ARMA model for
the squared residuals.
And so epsilon_t squared
is alpha_0 plus alpha_1
plus beta_1 the squared t minus
1 lag plus u_t minus beta_1
u_t.
And so what this implies is an
ARMA(1,1 model with white noise
that has mean 0 and variance
2 sigma to the fourth.
Just plugging things in.
And through our
knowledge, understanding,
of univariate time series
models, ARMA models,
we can express this ARMA model
for the squared residuals
as basically a polynomial
lag of the squared residuals
is equal to a polynomial
lag of the innovations.
And so we have this expression
for what the innovations are.
And it's required that the
roots of this a of L operator,
when it thought of
on the complex plane,
have roots outside
the unit circle, which
corresponds to alpha_1 plus
beta_1 being less than 1
in magnitude.
So in order for these
volatility models
not to blow up and be
stationary, covariance
stationary, we have these
bounds on the parameters.
OK, let's look at the
unconditional volatility
or long-run variance
of the GARCH model.
If you take expectations on
both sides of the GARCH model
equation, you basically have
the expectation of sigma
squared sub t--
in the long run is
sigma star squared-- is alpha_0
plus alpha_1 plus beta_1 sigma
star squared.
So that sigma star
squared there is
the expectation of the t
minus 1 volatility squared
in the limit.
And then you can
just solve for this
and see that sigma star
squared is equal alpha_0 over 1
minus alpha_1 minus beta_1.
And in terms of the stationarity
conditions for the process,
if the long-run variance, in
order for that to be finite,
you need alpha_1 plus beta_1
to be less than 1 in magnitude.
And if you consider the
general GARCH(p,1) model,
then the same argument leads to
a long-run variance being equal
to alpha_0, the sort of
intercept term in the GARCH
model, divided by 1 minus the
sum of all the parameters.
So these GARCH models
lead to constraints
on the parameters that are
important to incorporate
when we're doing any estimation
of these underlying parameters.
And it does complicate
things, actually.
So with maximum
likelihood estimation,
the routine for maximum
likelihood estimation
is the same for all models.
We basically want to
determine the likelihood
function of our data given
the unknown parameters.
And the likelihood function
is the probability density
function of the data
conditional on the parameters.
So our likelihood
function as a function
of the unknown parameters
c, alpha, and beta
is the value of the probability
density, the joint density
of all the data conditional
on those parameters.
And that joint
density function can
be expressed as the product
of successive conditional
expectations of the time series.
And those conditional densities
are normal random variables.
So we can just plug
in what we know
to be the probability
densities of normals
for the t-th
innovation epsilon_t.
And we just optimize
that function.
Now, the challenge with
estimating these GARCH models
in part is the constraints
on the underlying parameters.
Those need to be enforced.
So we have to have that the
alpha_i are greater than 0.
Also, the beta_j
are greater than 0.
And the sum of all of
them is between 0 and 1.
Who in this class has had
courses in numerical analysis
and done some
optimization of functions?
Non-linear functions?
Anybody?
OK.
Well, in addressing this kind
of problem, which will come up
with any complex model
that you need to estimate,
say via maximum likelihood,
the optimization methods
do really well if you're
optimizing a convex function,
finding the minimum
of a convex function.
And it's always nice
to do minimization
over sort of an unconstrained
range of underlying parameters.
And one of the tricks in
solving these problems
is to transform the
parameters to a scale
where they're unlimited
in range, basically.
So if you have a
positive random variable,
you might use to log of
that variable as the thing
to be optimizing over.
If the variable's
between 0 and 1,
then you might use
that variable divided
by 1 minus that variable and
then take the log of that.
And that's unconstrained.
So there are tricks for how
you do this optimization, which
come into play.
Anyway, that's the likelihood
with the normal distribution.
And we have computer
programs that
will solve that directly
so we don't have to worry
about this particular case.
Once we fit this model,
we want to evaluate
how good it is and
the evaluation is
based upon looking at the
residuals from the model.
So what we have are
these innovations,
epsilon hat t, which should
be distributed with variance
or volatility sigma hat t.
Those should be uncorrelated
with themselves or at least
to the extent that they can be.
And the squared
standardized residuals
should also be uncorrelated.
What we're trying to
do with these models
is to capture the
dependence, actually,
in the squared residuals, which
is measuring the magnitude
of the excess returns.
So those should be uncorrelated.
There are various
test for normality.
I've listed some of those that
are the most popular here.
And then there's issues of model
selection for deciding sort
of which GARCH model to apply.
I wanted to go
through an example
of this analysis with the
euro-dollar exchange rate.
So let me go to this
case study note.
So let's see.
There's a package in R called
rugarch for univariate GARCH
models, which fits various
GARCH models with different--
and fits them by
maximum likelihood.
So with this packet-- with
this particular library in R,
I fit the GARCH
model after actually
fitting the mean process for
the exchange rate returns.
Now, when we looked
at things last time,
we basically looked at
modeling the squared returns.
In fact, there may be an
underlying mean process that
needs to be specified as well.
So in this section
of the case note,
I initially fit an
autoregressive process
using the Akaike
information criterion
to choose the order of
the autoregressive process
and then fit a GARCH model
with normal GARCH terms.
And this is a plot of
the normal q-q plot
of the autoregressive residuals.
And what you can see is
that the points lie along
a straight line sort of in
the middle of the range.
But on the extremes, they
depart from that straight line.
This basically is a measure
of standardized quantiles.
So in terms of
standard units away
from the mean for
the residuals, we
tend to get many more high
values and many more low values
with the Gaussian distribution.
So that really isn't
fitting very well.
If we proceed and fit--
OK, actually that plot
was just the simple ARCH
model with no GARCH terms.
And then this is the graph of
the q-q plot with the Gaussian
assumption.
So here we can see that the
residuals from this model
are suggesting that it may
do a pretty good job when
things are only a few standard
deviations away from the mean.
Less than 2, 2.5.
But when we get to
more extreme values,
this isn't modeling things well.
So one alternative
is to consider
a heavier-tailed distribution
than the normal, namely
the t distribution.
And consider identifying
what t distribution best
fits the data.
So let's just look at what ends
up being the maximum likelihood
estimate for the degrees
of freedom parameter, which
is 10 degrees of freedom.
This shows the q-q
plot when you have
a non-Gaussian
distribution that's
t with 10 degrees of freedom.
It basically is explaining
these residuals quite well,
so that's accommodating the
heavier-tailed distribution
of these values.
With this GARCH
model, let's see--
if you compare sort of estimates
of volatility under the GARCH
and ARCH models--
the GARCH models
with the t distribution-- sorry
t distribution versus Gaussian.
Here's just a graph
showing time series plots
of the estimated
volatility over time, which
actually look quite close.
But when you look
at the differences,
there really are differences.
And so it turns out that
the volatility function
or the volatility estimate
GARCH models with Gaussian
versus GARCH with
t distributions
are really very, very similar.
And the heavier
tailed distribution
of the t distribution
means that the distribution
of actual volatility is greater.
But in terms of
estimating the volatility,
you have quite similar estimates
of the volatility coming out.
And this display--
which you'll be
able to see more clearly in the
case notes that I'll post up--
show that these are really
quite similar in magnitude.
And the value at risk concept
that was just-- by Ken couple
weeks ago in his lecture
from Morgan Stanley--
concerns the issue
of estimating what
is the likelihood of returns
exceeding some threshold.
And if we use the t distribution
for measuring variability
of the excess returns, then
the computations in the notes
indicate how you would compute
these value at risk limits.
If you compare
the t distribution
with a Gaussian distribution at
these nominal levels for value
at risk of like 2.5%
or 5%, surprisingly you
won't get too much difference.
It's really in looking at
sort of the extreme tails
of the distribution that
things come into play.
And so I wanted to show you how
that plays out by showing you
another graph here.
Those of you who have had
a statistics course before
have heard that sort
of a t distribution
can be a good
approximation to a normal--
or it can be approximated
well by a normal
if the degrees of freedom
for the t are at some level.
And who wants to suggest
a degrees of freedom
that you might
have before you're
comfortable approximating
a t with a normal?
Danny?
AUDIENCE: 30 or 40.
PROFESSOR: 30 or 40.
Sometimes people say even 25.
Above 25, you can almost
expect the t distribution
to be a good approximation
to the normal.
Well, this is a graph the
PDF for a standard normal
versus a standard t with
30 degrees of freedom.
And you can see that the density
functions are very, very close.
The standard-- the CDFs,
the cumulative distribution
functions, which is
the likelihood of being
less than or equal to the
horizontal value, ranges
between 0 and 1, is
almost indistinguishable.
But if you look at the
tails of the distribution,
here I've computed the
log of the CDF function.
You basically have
to move much more
than two standard deviations
away from the mean
before there's really
a difference in the t
distribution with 30
degrees of freedom.
Now I'm going to
page up by reducing
the degrees of freedom.
Let's see.
If we could do a page down here.
Page down.
Oh, page up.
OK.
So here is 20
degrees of freedom.
Here's 10 degrees of
freedom, in our case,
which turns out to be sort
of the best fit of the t
distribution.
And what you can see is that,
in terms of standard deviation
units, up to about two standard
deviations below the mean,
we're basically getting
virtually the same probability
mass at the extreme below.
But as we go to four or
six standard deviations,
then we get heavier mass
with the t distribution.
In discussion of
results in finance
when you sort of fit models,
people talk about, oh, there
was six standard deviation
move or-- which is just
virtually impossible to occur.
Well, with t distributions a
six standard deviation move
occurs about 1 in 10,000
times according to this fit.
And so it actually is a
common [? idiomatic. ?]
And so it's important to know
that these t distributions are
benefiting us by giving us
a much better gauge of what
the tail distribution is like.
And we call these
distributions leptokurtic,
meaning they're heavier tailed
than a normal distribution.
Actually, lepto means
slender, I believe,
if you're Greek or have the
Greek origin of the word.
And you can see that
the blue curve, which
is the t distribution, is
sort of a bit more slender
in the center of the
distribution, which allows
it to have heavier tails.
All right.
So t distributions
are very useful.
Let's go back to
this case note here
which discusses-- this
case note goes through,
actually, fitting
the t distribution--
identifying the degrees of
freedom for this t model.
And so with the
rugarch package, we
can get the log-likelihood
of the data fit
under the t
distribution assumption.
And here's a graph of the
negative log-likelihood
versus the degrees of
freedom in the t model.
So with maximum
likelihood we identify
the value which minimizes
the negative log likelihood.
And that comes out
as that 10 value.
All right.
Let's go back to these
notes and see what
else we want to talk about.
All right.
OK, with these GARCH
models we actually
are able to model
volatility clustering.
And volatility clustering
is where, over time, you
expect volatility to be
high during some periods
and to be low during
other periods.
And the GARCH model
can accommodate that.
So large volatilities
tend to be followed
by large, small
volatilities tend
to be followed by small ones.
OK.
The returns have heavier tails
than Gaussian distributions.
Actually, even if we have
Gaussian errors in the GARCH
model, it's still heavier
tailed than a Gaussian.
The homework goes into
that a little bit.
And the-- well, actually
one of the original papers
by Engle with Bollerslev, who
introduced the GARCH model,
discusses these
features and how useful
they are for modeling
financial time series.
Now, a property of these models
that may be obvious, perhaps,
but it is-- OK,
these are models that
are appropriate for modeling
covariance stationary time
series.
So the volatility
measure, which is
a measure of the
squared excess return,
is basically a covariance
stationary process.
So what does that mean?
That means that's going
to have a long-term mean.
So with these GARCH models
that are covariance stationary,
there's going to be a long-term
mean of the GARCH process.
And this discussion here
details how this GARCH process
is essentially a mean
reversion of the volatility
to that value.
So basically, the sort
of excess volatility
of the squared
residuals relative
to their long-term
average is some multiple
of the previous period's
excess volatility.
So if we build forecasting
models of volatility
with GARCH models,
what's going to happen?
Basically, in the
long run we predict
that any volatility
value is going to revert
to this long-run average.
And in the short run, it's
going to move incrementally
to that value.
So these GARCH models are very
good for describing volatility
relative to the
long-term average.
In terms of their
usefulness for prediction,
well, they really
predict that volatility
is going to revert back
to the mean at some rate.
And the rate at which the
volatility reverts back
is given by alpha_1 plus beta_1.
So that number,
which is less than 1
for covariance
stationarity, is sort
of measuring, basically, how
quickly you are reverting back
to the mean.
And that sum is actually
called a persistence parameter
in GARCH models as well.
So is volatility
persisting or not?
Well, the larger
alpha_1 plus beta_1
is, the more persistent
volatility is, meaning it's
reverting back to that long-run
average very, very slowly.
In the implementation
of volatility estimates
with the risk
metrics methodology,
they actually don't assume that
there is a long-run volatility.
And so that basically you'll
have alpha_1 be equal to 0
and beta_1 equal to, say, 0.95.
So or rather the alpha_0 is
0 and the alpha_1 and beta_1
will actually sum to 1.
And so you actually are tracking
a potentially non-stationary
volatility, which allows you
to be estimating the volatility
without presuming a
long-run average is
consistent with the past.
There are many extensions
of the GARCH models.
And there's wide
literature on that.
For this course, I think
it's important to understand
the fundamentals of
these models in terms
of how they're specified under
Gaussian and t assumptions.
Extending them can
be very interesting.
And there are many papers
to look at for that.
OK.
let's pause for a minute
and get the next topic.
All right.
The next topic is time series,
multivariate time series.
In two lectures ago
of mine, we talked
about univariate time series
and basic methodologies there.
We're now going to be
extending that to multivariate
time series.
Turns out there's a multivariate
Wold representation theorem,
extension of the univariate one.
There are
autoregressive processes
for multivariate
cases, which are vector
autoregressive processes.
Least squares estimation
comes into play.
And then we'll see where
our regression analysis
understanding
allows us to specify
these vector autoregressive
processes nicely.
There's an optimality properties
of ordinary least squares
estimates component wise, which
we'll highlight in about a half
an hour.
And go through the maximum
likelihood estimation model
selection methods,
which are just
very straightforward
extensions of the same concepts
for univariate time series
and univariate regressions.
So let's talk-- let's
introduce the notation
for multivariate time series.
We have a stochastic process,
which now is multivariate.
So we have bold X of t is
some m-dimensional valued
random variable.
And it's a stochastic process
that varies over time t.
And we can think of this
as m different time series
corresponding to the m
components of the given
process.
So, say, with exchange
rates we could
be modeling m different exchange
rate values and want to model
those jointly as a time series.
Or we could have collections
of stocks that we're modeling.
So each of the
components individually
can be treated as univariate
series with univariate methods.
With the multivariate
case, we extend
the definition of
covariance stationarity
to correspond to finite, bounded
first and second order moments.
So we need to talk
about the first order
moment of the
multivariate time series.
Mu now is an m vector, which is
the vector of expected values
of the individual
components, which we can
denote by mu_1 through mu_m.
So we basically have m
vectors for our mean.
Then for the
variance/covariance matrix,
let's define gamma_0 to be
the variance/covariance matrix
of the t-th observation of
our multivariate process.
So that's equal to the
expected value of X_t minus mu
X_t minus mu prime.
So when we write that
down, we have X_t minus mu.
This is basically
an m by 1 vector
and then X_t minus mu
prime is a 1 by m vector.
And so the product of that
is an m by m quantity.
So the 1, 1 element of that
product is the variance
of X_(1,t).
And the diagonal entries
are the variances
of the components series.
And the off-diagonal
values are the covariance
between the i-th row series
and the j-th column series,
as given by the i-th row of
X and the j-th column of X
transpose.
So we're just
collecting together
all the variances/covariances
together.
And the notation is very
straightforward and simple
with the matrix
notation given here.
Now, the correlation matrix,
r_0, is obtained by pre-
and post-multiplying this
covariance matrix gamma_0
by a diagonal matrix
with the square roots
of the diagonal of this matrix.
Now what's a correlation?
Correlation is the correlation
between two random variables
where we've standardized
the variables
to have mean 0 and variance 1.
So what we want to do is
basically divide through all
of these variables by
their standard deviation
and compute the covariance
matrix on that new scaling.
That's equivalent to just
pre- and post-multiplying
by that diagonal of the inverse
of the standard deviations.
So with matrix
algebra, that formula
is-- I think it's very clear.
And this is-- now with-- the
previous discussion was just
looking at the sort of
contemporaneous covariance
matrix of the time series
values at the given time
t with itself.
We want to look at, also, the
cross-covariance matrices.
So how are the current values
of the multivariate time series,
X_t-- how do they covary with
the k-th lag of those values?
So gamma_k is looking at how
the current period vector
values is covaried with the
k-th lag of those values.
So this covariance matrix
has covariance elements
given in this display.
And we can define the
cross-correlation matrix
by similarly pre-
and post-multiplying
by the inverse of the
standard deviations.
The diagonal of gamma_0
is the covariance--
or is the matrix of diagonal
entries of variances.
Now, properties of
these matrices is-- OK,
gamma_0 is a symmetric
matrix that we had before.
But gamma k where k is
greater than 1 or less than--
or greater or equal to 1 or
less than-- basically different
from 0.
This is not symmetric.
Basically, you may have
lags of some variables that
are positively correlated with
others and not vice versa.
So the off-diagonal entries
here aren't necessarily even
of the same sign, let
alone equal and symmetric.
So with these
covariance matrices,
one can look at
how things covary
and whether they are--
whether there is, basically,
a dependence between them.
And you can define--
it's basically the j star
series-- the j star component
of the multivariate time series
may lead the j-th one if the
covariance of the k-th lag of j
star is different from 0--
or the covariance of j star k
lags ago is non-zero,
covaries with the j-th lag.
Sorry.
The current lag.
So X_(t, j star)
will lead X_(t, j).
Basically, there's information
in the lagged values
of j star for the component j.
So if we're trying to build
models-- linear regression
models, even, where we're
trying to look at how-- trying
to predict values, then if
there's a non-zero covariance,
then we can use those
variables' information
to actually project what the
one variable is given the other.
Now, it can be the case that
you have non-zero covariance
in both directions.
And so that suggests
that there can
be sort of feedback
between these variables.
It's not just that one
variable causes another,
but there can
actually be feedback.
In economics and
finance, there's
a notion of Granger causality.
And basically that--
well, Granger and Engle
got the Nobel Prize number of
years ago based on their work.
And that work deals
with identifying,
in part, judgments of
causality between--
or Granger causality
between variables
in economic time series.
And so Granger
causality basically
is sort of positive or non-zero
correlation between variables
where lags of one variable will
cause another or cause changes
in another.
All right.
I want to just alert you to
the existence of this Wold
decomposition theorem.
This is an advanced theorem,
but it's a useful theorem
to know exists.
And this extends the univariate
Wold decomposition theorem,
which concerns the--
whenever we have
a covariant stationary
process, there
exists a representation
of that process, which
is the sum of a deterministic
process and a moving
average process
of a white noise.
So if you're modeling
a time series
and you're going
to be specifying
a covariance stationary
process for that,
there does exist a Wold
decomposition representation
of that.
You can basically
determine-- identify
the deterministic process
that the process might follow.
It might be a linear trend over
time or an exponential trend.
And if you remove that sort
of deterministic process V_t,
then what remains
is a process that
can be modeled with a moving
average of white noise, these.
Now here, everything is
changed from univariate case
to multivariate case, so we have
matrices in place of constants
from before.
So these-- new
concepts here are we
have a multivariate
white noise process.
That's going to be a process
eta_t which is m-dimensional
which has mean 0.
And the variance
matrix of this m-vector
is going to be sigma, which is
now m by m variance/covariance
matrix of the components.
And that must be a
positive semi-definite.
And for white noise, we have
covariances between, say,
the current t innovation and
a lag of its value are 0.
So these are uncorrelated
multivariate white noise
processes.
And so they're uncorrelated
with each other at various lags.
And the innovation eta_t
has a covariance of 0
with the deterministic process.
Actually, that's
pretty much a given
if we have a
deterministic process.
Now, the term
psi_k-- basically we
have this m-vector X_t is equal
to some m-vectored process
V_t plus this weighted
average of innovations.
What's required is that the sum
of this-- basically each term
psi_k and its
transpose converges.
Now, if you were to
take that X_t process
and say let me compute the
variance/covariance matrix
of that representation,
then you would basically
get terms in the
covariance matrix which
includes this sum of terms.
So that sum has to be
finite in order for this
to be covariance stationary.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you define
what you mean by innovation?
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
Well, the innovation
is-- let's see.
With-- let me go back up here.
OK.
The innovation process--
innovation process.
OK, if we have, as
in this case, we
have sort of our X_t
stochastic process.
And we have sort of, say,
f sub t minus 1 equal
to the information on
X_(t-1), X_(t-2)...
Basically consisting of the
information set available
before time t.
Then we can model X_t to be
the expected value of X_t given
F_(t-1) plus an innovation.
And so our objective
in these models
is to be thinking of how is that
process evolving where we can
model the process as well as
possible using information up
to time before t.
And then there's some
disturbance about that model.
There's something new that's
happened at time t that
wasn't available before.
And that's this
innovation process.
So this representation
with the Wold decomposition
is converting the-- or
representing, basically,
the bits of information that
are affecting the process that
are occurring at time t and
wasn't available prior to that.
All right.
Well, let's move on to vector
autoregressive processes.
OK, this representation for a
vector autoregressive process
is an extension of the
univariate autoregressive
process to p dimensions.
Sorry, to m dimensions.
And so our X_t is an m-vector.
That's going to be equal to some
constant vector C plus a matrix
phi_1 times lag of X_t
first order, X_(t-1).
Plus another matrix, phi_2 times
the second lag of X_t, X_(t-2).
Up to the p-th term, which is
a phi_p, m by m matrix times,
X_(t-p) plus this
innovation term.
So this is essentially--
this is basically
how a univariate
autoregressive process extends
to an m-variate case.
And what this
allows one to do is
model how a given component
of the multivariate series--
like how one
exchange rate varies
depending on how other
exchange rates might vary.
Exchange rates tend to co-move
together in that example.
So if we look at
what this represents
in terms of basically
a component series,
we can consider
fixing j, a component
of the multivariate process.
It could be the first,
the last, or the j-th,
somewhere in the middle.
And that component
time series-- like
a fixed exchange
rate series or time
series, whatever we're
focused on in our modeling--
is a generalization of the
autoregressive model where
we have the autoregressive
terms of the j-th series on lags
of the j-th series
up to order p.
So we have the univariate
autoregressive model,
but we also add to that
terms corresponding
to the relationship
between X_j and X_(j star).
So how does X_j,
the j-th component,
depend on other variables,
other components
of the multivariate series.
And those are given here.
So it's a convenient way to
allow for interdependence
among the components
and model that.
OK.
This slide deals with
representing a p-th order
process as a first order process
with vector autoregressions.
Now the concept here is really
a very powerful concept that's
applied in time
series methods, which
is when you are modeling
dependence that goes back, say,
a number of lags like
p lags, the structure
can actually be re-expressed
as simply a first order
dependence only.
And so it's much easier sort
of to deal with just a lag one
dependence than to
consider p lag dependence
and the complications
involved with that.
So-- and this
technique is one where,
in the early days of fitting,
like autoregressive moving
average processes and
various smoothing methods,
the model-- basically
accommodating
p lags complicated the
analysis enormously.
But one can actually
re-express it just
as a first order lag problem.
So in this case, what
one does is one considers
for a vector autoregressive
process of order of p,
simply stacking the
values of the process.
So let me just highlight
what's going on there.
So if we have basically--
OK, so if we have X_1,
X_2, X_n, which are
all m by 1 values,
m-vectors of the
stochastic process.
Then consider defining Z_t
to be equal to X_t transpose,
X_(t-1) transpose up
to X_(t-p-1) transpose.
Or this is t minus (p-1).
So there are p terms.
And then if we consider
the lagged value of that,
that's X_(t-1), X_(t-2),
X_(t-p) transpose.
So what we've done is
we're considering Z_t.
This is going to be m times p.
It's actually 1 by m
times p in this notation.
Well, actually I guess I
should put transpose here.
So m times p by 1.
OK, in the lecture
notes it actually
is primed there to
indicate the transpose.
Well, if you define Z_t
and Z_(t-1) this way,
then Z_t is equal to D
plus A of Z_(t-1) plus F.
Where this is d, basically
the constant term has the C
entering and then
0's everywhere else.
And the A matrix is
phi_1, phi_2, up to phi_p.
And so basically the Z_t
vector transforms the Z_t--
or is the transform--
this linear transformation
of the Z_(t-1).
And we have sort of
a very simple form
for the constant term and a very
simple form for the F vector.
And this is-- renders the model
into a sort of a first order
time series model with a
larger multivariate series,
basically mp by 1.
Now, with this representation
we basically have-- we
can demonstrate that the process
is going to be stationary
if all eigenvalues of
the companion matrix A
have modulus less than 1.
And let's see-- if we go
back to the expression.
OK, if the eigenvalues of
this matrix A are less than 1,
then we won't get sort
of an explosive behavior
of the process when this
basically increments over time
with every previous
value getting
multiplied by the A matrix and
scaling the process over time
by the A-th power.
So that is required.
All eigenvalues of A
have to be less than 1.
And equivalently, all
roots of this equation
need to be outside
the unit circle.
You remember there was a
constraint of-- or a condition
for univariate
autoregressive models
to be stationary, that the roots
of the characteristic equation
are all outside the unit circle.
And the class notes
go through and went
through the derivation of that.
This is the extension of that
to the multivariate case.
And so basically
one needs to solve
for roots of a polynomial in
z and determine whether those
are outside the unit circle.
Who can tell me what the
order of the polynomial
is here for this sort
of determinant equation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] mp.
PROFESSOR: mp.
Yes.
It's basically of power mp.
So in a determinant
you basically
are taking products
of the m components
in the matrix, various
linear combinations of those.
So that's going to be an
mp-dimensional polynomial.
All right.
Well, the mean of the
stationary VAR process
can be computed rather
easily by taking expectations
of this on both sides.
So if we take the
expectation of X_t
and take expectations
across both sides,
we get that mu is the C vector
plus the product of the phi_k's
times mu plus 0.
So mu, the unconditional
mean of the process,
actually has this
formula, just solving
for mu in the top-- in the
second line to the third line.
So here we can see that
basically this expression 1
minus phi_1 through phi_p,
that inverse has to exist.
And actually, if we then
plug in the value of C
in terms of the
unconditional mean,
we get this expression
for the original process.
So the unconditional mean C,
if we demeaned the process,
there's basically no mean term.
There's 0.
And so basically the
mean-adjusted process
X follows this multivariate
vector autoregression
with no mean, which is actually
used when this is specified.
Now, this vector
autoregression model
can be expressed as a system
of regression equations.
And so what we have with the
multivariate series, if we have
multivariate data, we'll have
n sample observations x_t,
which is basically the m-vector
of the multivariate process
observed for n time points.
And for the
computations here, we're
going to assume that
we have p sort of-- we
have pre-sample observations
available to us.
So we're essentially going
to be considering models
where we condition
on the first p time
points in order to facilitate
the estimation methodology.
Then we can set up m
regression models corresponding
to each component of
the m-variate series.
And so what we have
is our original--
we have our collection of data
values, which is x_1 transpose,
x_2 transpose, down
to x_n transpose,
which is an n by m matrix.
OK, this is our
multivariate time series
where we were
just-- the first row
corresponds to the first time
values, nth row to the nth time
values.
And we can set up
m regression models
where we're going
to consider modeling
the j-th column of this matrix.
So we're just picking out
the univariate time series
corresponding to
the j-th component.
That's y j.
And we're going to
model that as Z beta j
plus epsilon j where Z is given
by the vector of lagged values
of the multivariate
process where there's,
for the t-th-- t
minus first value
we have that current
value-- or the t
minus first, t minus
second, up to t minus p.
So we have basically
p m-vectors here.
And so this j-th time
series has elements
that follow a linear
regression model
on the lags of the entire
multivariate series up to p
lags with their regression
parameter given by beta j.
And basically the beta
j regression parameters
corresponds to the various
elements of the phi matrices.
So now there's a one-to-one one
correspondence between those.
All right.
So I'm using now a notation
where superscript j corresponds
to the j-th component
of the series,
of the multivariate
stochastic process.
So we have an mp plus 1 vector
of regression parameters
for each series j, and
we have an epsilon j
for-- an n-vector of innovation
errors for each series.
And so basically if this,
the j-th column, is y j,
we're modeling that to be
equal to the simple matrix
Z times beta j plus epsilon
j, where this is n by 1.
This is n by np plus 1.
And this beta j is the mp
plus 1 regression parameter.
OK.
One might think,
OK, one can consider
each of these regressions for
each of the component series,
you could consider
them separately.
But to consider
them all together,
we can define the
multivariate regression model,
which has the following form.
We basically have the n-vectors
for the first component,
and then the second component
up to nth component.
So an n by p matrix of
dependent variables,
where each column corresponds
to a different component series,
follows a linear
regression model
with the same Z matrix
with different regression
coefficient parameters, beta
1 through beta m corresponding
to the different components
of the multivariate series.
And we have epsilon 1,
epsilon 2, up to epsilon m.
So we're thinking of taking--
so basically the y 1, y 2,
up to y m is essentially
this original matrix
of our multivariate
time series because it's
the first component
in the first column
and the nth component
in the nth column.
And the-- this
regression parameter
or this explanatory variables
matrix X, Z in this case
corresponds to lags of the
whole process up to p lags.
So we're having
lags of all the--
the m-variate
process up to p lags.
So that's mp and then
plus 1 for our constant.
So this is the set up for a
multivariate regression model.
In terms of how
one specifies this,
well, actually,
in economic theory
this is also related
to seemingly unrelated
regressions, which you'll
find in econometrics.
If we want to specify this
multivariate model, well,
what we could do is
we could actually
specify each of the
component models
separately because we
basically have sort of-- can
think of the
univariate regression
model for each component series.
And this slide
indicates basically what
the formulas are for that.
So if we don't know anything
about multivariate regression
we can say, well,
let's start by just
doing the univariate regression
of each component series
on the lags.
And so we get our beta
hat j's least squares
estimates given by the
usual formula where
the independent variables matrix
Z goes Z transpose Z inverse Z
transpose Y are the residuals.
So these are familiar formulas.
And if we did this for each
of the component series j,
then we would actually
get sample estimates
of the innovation process,
the eta_1, basically
the whole eta series.
And we could actually
define from these estimates
of the innovations
our covariance matrix
for the innovations as
the sample covariance
matrix of these etas.
So all of these formulas
are-- you're basically
applying very
straightforward estimation
methods for the parameters
of a linear regression
and then estimating
variances/covariances
of these innovation terms.
So from this, we
actually have estimates
of this process in terms of
the sigma and the beta hats.
But it's made
assuming that we can
treat each of these component
regressions separately.
A rather remarkable
result is that
these component-wise
regressions are actually
the optimal estimates for
the multivariate regression
as well.
And as mathematicians,
this kind of result
is, I think, rather
neat and elegant.
And maybe some of you will
think this is very obvious,
but it actually-- it
isn't quite obvious.
That said, this
component-wise estimation
should be optimal as well.
And the next section
of the lecture notes
goes through this argument.
And I'm going to, in
the interest of time,
go through this-- just sort of
highlight what the results are.
The details are in these
notes that you can go through.
And I will be happy to go
into more detail about them
during office hours.
But if we're fitting a vector
autoregression model where
there are no constraints
on the coefficient
matrices phi_1
through phi_p, then
these component-wise
estimates, accounting
for arbitrary covariance matrix
sigma for the innovations,
those basically are equal
to the generalized least
squares estimates of these
underlying parameters.
You'll recall we talked about
the Gauss-Markov theorem
where we were able to extend the
assumption of equal variances
across observations to unequal
variances and covariances.
Well, it turns out to
these component-wise OLS
estimates are, in fact, the
generalized least squared
estimates.
And under the assumption
of Gaussian distributions
for the innovations,
they, in fact,
are maximum
likelihood estimates.
And this theory applies
Kronecker products.
We're not going to have
any homework with Kronecker
products.
These notes really
are for those who
have some more extensive
background in linear algebra.
But it's a very nice use
of these Kronecker product
operators.
Basically, this
notation-- I don't
know, x circle, I'll
call it Kronecker--
is one where you take a
matrix A and a matrix B
and you consider
the matrix which
takes each element of A times
the whole matrix B. So we start
with an m by n matrix A and
end up with an mp by qn matrix
by taking each element of
A times the whole matrix B.
So it's, they say, has
this block structure.
So this is very
simple definition.
If you look at properties of
transposition of matrices,
you can prove these results.
These are properties of
the Kronecker product.
And there's a vec operator
which takes a matrix
and simply stacks
the columns together.
And in the talk last Tuesday of
Ivan's, talking about modeling
the volatility surface,
he basically, he
was modeling a two dimensional
surface-- or a surface
in three dimensions,
but there was
two dimensions explaining it.
You basically can stack
columns of the matrix
and be modeling a vector
instead of a matrix of values.
So the vectorizing operator
allows us to manipulate terms
into a more convenient form.
And this multivariate
regression model
is one where it's set up as
sort of a n by m matrix Y,
having that structure.
It can be expressed in terms
of the linear regression form
as y star equaling the
vector, the vec of y.
So we basically have y 1, y
2, down to y m all lined up.
So this is pm by 1.
That's going to be equal to
some matrix plus the epsilon 1,
epsilon 2, down to epsilon n.
And then there's
going to be a matrix
and a regression
coefficient matrix beta
1, beta 2, down to beta p.
So we consider vectorizing
the beta matrix,
vectorizing epsilon,
and vectorizing y.
And then in order
to define this sort
of simple linear regression
model, univariate regression
model, well, we need to
have a Z in the first column
here corresponding to beta 1 for
y 1, and 0's everywhere else.
In the second block
we want to have
a Z in the second off diagonal
with 0's everywhere else and so
forth.
So this is just re-expressing
everything in this notation.
But the notation is very nice
because, at the end of the day
we basically have a regression
model like we had when we were
doing our regression analysis.
So all the theory we have
for specifying these models
plays through with
univariate regression.
And one can go through
this technical argument
to show that the
generalized least squares
estimate is, in
fact, the equivalent
to the component-wise values.
And that's very, very good.
Maximum likelihood
estimation with these models.
Well, we actually use
this vectorized notation
to define the
likelihood function.
And if these
assumptions are made
about the linear
regression model,
we basically have
an n times m vector
of dependent variable values,
whereas your multivariate
normal with mean given
by x star beta star
and then a covariance
matrix epsilon.
The covariance matrix of
epsilon star is sigma star.
Well, sigma star is I_n
Kronecker product sigma.
So if you go through
the math of this,
everything matches up in terms
of what the assumptions are.
And the conditional probability
density function of this data
is the usual functions
of log-normal
or of a normal sample.
So we have unknown
parameters beta star sigma,
which are equal to
the joint density
of this normal linear
regression model.
So this corresponds to what we
had before in our regression
analysis.
We just had this more
complicated definition
of the independent
variables matrix X star.
And a more
complicated definition
of our variance/covariance
matrix sigma star.
But the log-likelihood
function ends up
being equal to a
term proportional
to the log of the determinant
of our sigma matrix
and minus one half Q of beta
sigma, where Q of beta sigma
is the least squares criterion
for each of the component
models summed up.
So the component-wise
maximum likelihood estimation
is-- for the
underlying parameters,
is the same as the large one.
And in terms of estimating
the covariance matrix,
there's a notion called the
concentrated log-likelihood,
which comes into play in
models with many parameters.
In this model, we have
unknown parameters--
our regression parameters
beta and our covariance matrix
for the innovations sigma.
It turns out that our estimate
of the regression parameter
beta is independent, doesn't
depend-- not statistically
independent-- but
does not depend
on the value of the
covariance matrix sigma.
So whatever sigma is, we have
the same maximum likelihood
estimate for the betas.
So we can consider
the log-likelihood
setting the beta parameter
equal to its maximum likelihood
estimate.
And then we have a
function that just
depends on the data and the
unknown parameter sigma.
So that's a concentrated
likelihood function
that needs to be maximized.
And the maximization of the log
of a determinant of a matrix
minus n over 2 the trace of that
matrix times an estimate of it,
that has been solved.
It's a bit involved.
But if you're interested in
the mathematics for how that's
actually solved and how you
take derivatives of determinants
and so forth, there's a
paper by Anderson and Olkin
that goes through all
the details of that
that you can Google on the web.
Finally, let's see.
There's-- well, not finally.
There's model selection
criteria that can be applied.
These have been applied
before for regression models
for univariate time series
model, the Akaike Information
Criterion, the Bayes Information
Criterion, Hannan-Quinn
Criterion.
These definitions
are all consistent
with the other definitions.
They basically take
the likelihood function
and you try to maximize that
plus a penalty for the number
of unknown parameters.
And that's given here.
OK, then the last
section goes through
an asymptotic distribution
of least squares estimates.
And I'll let you read
that on your own.
Let's see.
For this lecture I put
together an example
of fitting vector
autoregressions
with some macroeconomic
variables.
And I just wanted to
point that out to you.
So let me go to
this document here.
What have we got here?
All right.
Well, OK.
Modeling macroeconomic time
series is an important topic.
It's what sort of
central bankers do.
They want to
understand what factors
are affecting the economy in
terms of growth, inflation,
unemployment.
And what's the impact of
interest rate policies.
There are some really
important papers
by Robert Litterman and
Christopher Sims dealing
with fitting vector
autoregression models
to a macroeconomic time series.
And actually, the
framework within which
they specified these models
was a Bayesian framework,
which is an extension of the
maximum likelihood method where
you'll incorporate reasonable
sort of prior assumptions
about what the
parameters ought to be.
But in this note,
I sort of basically
go through collecting various
macroeconomic variables
directly off the web
using the package R.
All this stuff
is-- these are data
that you can get your hands on.
Here's the unemployment
rate from January 1946
up through this past month.
Anyone can see how that's
varied between much less than 4%
to over 10%, as it was recently.
And there's also
the Fed funds rate,
which is one of
the key variables
that the Federal Reserve Open
Market Committee controls,
or I should say
controlled in the past,
to try and affect the economy.
Now that value of that
rate is set almost at zero
and other means
are applied to have
an impact on economic growth
and the economic situation
of the market-- of
the economy, rather.
Let's see.
There's also-- anyway, a
bunch of other variables.
CPI, which is a
measure of inflation.
What this note goes through
is the specification
of vector autoregression
models for these series.
And I use just a
small set of cases.
I look at unemployment
rate, federal funds,
and the CPI, which is
a measure of inflation.
And there's-- if
one goes through,
there are multivariate
versions of the autocorrelation
function, as given on
the top right panel here,
between these variables.
And one can also do the partial
autocorrelation function.
You'll recall that
autocorrelation functions
and partial
are related to what kind of--
or help us understand what kind
of order ARMA processes
might be appropriate
for univariate series.
For multivariate series,
then there are basically
cross lags between variables
that are important,
and these can call be captured
with vector autoregression
models.
So this goes through and
shows how these things
are correlated with themselves.
And let's see.
At the end of this note,
there are some impulse
response functions
graphed, which
are looking at what is the
impact of an innovation in one
of the components of the
multivariate time series.
So like if Fed funds were to be
increased by a certain value,
what would the likely impact
be on the unemployment rate?
Or on GNP?
Basically, the production
level of the economy.
And this looks at-- let's see.
Well, actually
here we're looking
at the impulse function.
You can look at the
impulse function
of innovations on any of
the component variables
on all the others.
And in this case,
on the left panel
here is-- it shows what
happens when unemployment
has a spike up, or unit spike.
A unit impulse up.
Well, this second
panel shows what's
likely to happen to
the Fed funds rate.
It turns out that's
likely to go down.
And that sort of is
indicating-- it's sort
of reflecting
what, historically,
was the policy of the Fed to
basically reduce interest rates
if unemployment was rising.
And then-- so anyway, these
impulse response functions
correspond to essentially those
innovation terms on the Wold
decomposition.
And why are these important?
Well, this indicates a
connection, basically,
between that sort of moving
average representation
and these time series models.
And the way these
graphs are generated
is by essentially finding
the Wold decomposition
and then incorporating
that into these values.
So-- OK, we'll finish
there for today.